hey guys it's Jonah here so are you new
to the gym do you feel absolutely lost
when it comes to using the gym equipment
or perhaps you're just too shy to ask a
trainer
well watch this video through I'm going
to show you how to use some of the basic
gym equipment and also each muscle group
you'll be working on so let's get into
the gym and let's start working out here
are a few quick tips all machines have
diagrams stating the major and minor
muscles being worked on the first thing
to look out for is the adjustment levers
which usually a bright-colored
so that they stand out how heavy should
you lift the weights should be heavy
enough to fatigue your muscles within 8
to 15 repetitions but not too heavy that
you struggle to complete a full range of
motion beginners if you're new to the
movements you can always start slightly
lighter and slowly increase the weight
as you get more comfortable with the
machines so let's begin this is the
seated row machine which basically works
on your back muscles
so the first adjustment point is the
seat
move the seat up or down so that the
support pad is directly in front of your
chest
grip the handles with the palms facing
each other keep your back flat chest
open and feet flat as you exhale pull
the handles and focus on squeezing your
shoulder blades together keep your
elbows bent and point it back hold for
two seconds inhale and slowly release to
the starting position avoid spreading
your elbows to the side
don't let your chest or tosser lift away
from the pad in front of you your chest
should always be in contact with the pad
and the only movement should
from your arms let's move on to see the
chest press the major muscle worked on
is your chest muscle and the secondary
muscles are your shoulders and triceps
adjust the seat height up or down so
that the handles are in line with the
chest level not above or below it sit
with your back fully against the chair
chest up and keep your abs tight hold
handles with your palms facing down and
elbows bent at a 90 degree angle use the
foot pedal to help you lift the weight
stack once it's lifted place your feet
flat on the floor as you exhale extend
your arms and push the handles forward
do not unlock your elbows always keep
them slightly bent squeeze the chest
muscles and hold for two counts inhale
and slowly release your arms to chest
level in a 90 degree angle and repeat
instead of using your shoulders keep
your shoulders relaxed and focus on
engaging your chest muscles this is the
leg extension machine which works
primarily on your quads there are three
main adjustment points so let's start by
adjusting the seat adjust the seat
forward or back until your back is fully
supported there shouldn't be any gap
when you're seated next adjust the foot
pad so that it's rested on the lowest
part of the shin just above your feet
then bring the leg support all the way
back until your legs are in a 90 degree
angle hold onto the handles on the side
of the machine this is your starting
position as you exhale extend your legs
upwards until your knees are straight
but not locked engage your quad muscles
hold and squeeze for one count inhale
and slowly lower the weights back down
to starting position ensuring that a
stack wait do not slam but they should
come close to touching
and repeat the Cedar Lake curl machine
works the opposite muscle which is the
hamstrings this machine also has three
main adjustment points again start by
adjusting the seat forward or back until
your back is fully supported with no gap
sit and place the back of your lower
legs on the pedal with rest you want to
adjust so that it's rested securely on
your ankles the lift of the lap pad
up so that your legs are fully extended
in front of you with your feet facing
forward hold the handles by your side
and keep both feet shoulder-width apart
as you exhale slowly bed at an ease to
curl the heels down towards at the back
of your thighs and get your hamstrings
hold the contracted position for a
second inhale and slowly release to the
starting position this is the shoulder
press machine which works primarily on
your shoulders and the secondary muscles
worked on are your triceps adjust the
seat height up or down so that the
handles are in line with your shoulder
level again always check that you're
seated with a back fully against at the
chair chest up and keeping your abs
tight hold the handles with the palms
facing forward and elbows bent at a 90
degree angle as you exhale extend your
arms straight up until they are fully
extended but do not lock at your elbows
hold the contracted position for two
counts and slowly release to starting
position and repeat the pack fly machine
is another machine which works on your
major chest muscles the minor muscles
worked on are your shoulders biceps and
also triceps first adjust the seat
height so that your back is firmly
rested against the pad and the handles
are at chest height next adjust the
handles so that they are directly by
your sides hold onto the handles with
the palms facing forward and extend your
arms straight out through the sides
keeping your elbows slightly bent
as you exhale bring the handles together
directly in front of you making sure
that both arms are still extended and
elbows slightly bent squeeze the chest
muscles and hold for two counts inhale
and slowly return to the starting
position and repeat you should feel a
mal stretch in your chest and shoulders
this machine also doubles up to work on
your rear delts oh the back shoulder
muscles the minor muscles targeted are
the legs mid-back and also your triceps
adjust the handles and bring them close
together reverse your sitting position
with the support pad directly in front
of your chest
grip the handles with the palms facing
each other at shoulder height as you
exhale spread your arms to the side and
backwards and focus on squeezing the
back of your shoulders together keep it
elbows straight but not locked
hold and squeeze for two counts then
inhale and slowly release to the
starting position again don't let your
chest lift away from the pad in front of
you your chest should always be in
contact with a pad and the only movement
should be from your arms this is an
assisted pull up machine which is a
great exercise to do if you want to
progress to do a full pull up the main
muscles engaged are the less this
machine uses counterbalance weights
which mean the heavier the weight you
set the easier the exercise becomes when
the weight you choose is lighter you're
lifting more of your body weights and
the exercise is harder so start by
setting the weight about twenty-five to
fifty percent less than your own weight
carefully climb onto the machine with
your feet firmly on the steps hold on to
the outer handles with your palms facing
forward and place your knees on the
padded knee rest keeping your abs
engaged back neutral and chest open
slowly lower yourself down with your
arms fully extended but keeping the
elbows bent exhale and
get your leg muscles and pull yourself
until your chin is above at the height
of your hands inhale and slowly lower
yourself back down and repeat make sure
to always keep your abs engaged and
avoid swinging your legs or body the
movements again it should only be from
your arms this machine also doubles up
as an assistant tricep dip the major
muscles wall caused by your triceps and
the minor muscles are the chest and also
showed us for this exercise grip the
lower bar handles with the palms facing
each other then slowly lower yourself
down until your elbows are bent at a 90
degree angle as you exhale use your
triceps to push yourself up extending
your arms straight by still keeping a
slight bend at the elbows and pointing
them back avoid spreading your elbows
out to the side keeping them pointed
back and close to your body one of the
best machines to work on your abs is at
the captain's chair Lake Race
it's a great machine to hit every part
of the core the secondary muscles worked
on are the hip flexors and also quads so
get onto the machine rest your forearms
and elbows on the support pads and hold
the boss firmly your back should be
pressed against the backrest keeping
your legs straight and together lift
them directly in front of you parallel
to the floor then slowly lower them down
and repeat engage and tighten your core
throughout the exercise for an easier
version you can start by bending your
knees and bringing them close to your
chest as you progress straighten your
legs
here are some guidelines stop by
performing each of the exercises for
eight to 15 repetitions and aim for 2 to
3 sets with a 30 to 60 seconds rest in
between keep track of your workout and
you can slowly progress by increasing
the weight
reducing the rest of time or increasing
each exercise to three to four sets
remember that proper form is extremely
important so always check that you're
performing the exercise in the correct
manner so guys I hope this video has
given you the courage to go into the gym
and start using the equipment don't be
intimidated okay if you have any
questions just ask one of the trainers
I'm sure they'll be more than willing to
help you like this video share this
video with your friends and check out
more beginners workout video right here
hit the subscribe button if you haven't
yet done it all the best and see you in
the gym